this man's cousin feels he's been
targeted by the twitterverse i think
robbie's been on the show
because his throwing motion looked
terrible and every now and then it pops
up
and so he and uh
his cousin came on the show to address
it
now
stephen amell is back here on the rich
eisen show after he targeted me one day
on the field at a super bowl
about how good looking i looked in
person that's how he became connected
and now stephen is one of the stars of
the
program heals on stars which airs
sundays at 9 00 pm eastern time stephen
amell back here on the show how was that
for an introduction stephen
it's really good rich it's uh it's the
best i've ever had frankly
it reminds me of uh reminds me of the
intro that carson did for bill clinton
when he was governor of arkansas it's
really really good thank you sir i
appreciate that stephen that's how i
feel about you um how you been what's
going on in your world
uh i've been great rich i'm i'm down in
uh down in austin on the lake with uh
with my family and just uh
building out a bonehouse down here doing
promotion for heels talking with you and
getting incredibly fired up because we
have wonderful season seats for the rams
at sofi stadium and we've been waiting
uh we had to wait next year so we're
gonna be there this sunday night you are
i don't think you yeah of course we have
season seats we'll be there and yes all
fired up man i'm i'm ready for the nfl
season well very ready stephen uh were
you about to say you don't think i'm
going to be there did i hear that
potentially words come out of your mouth
i just assumed because it was an mb well
i didn't know since it was an nbc game
but i mean if you're going to be there
i'm excited i just said i i don't
totally want to introduce you to my wife
because again i've seen how good looking
you are that's right
i know that that happened you tweeted
about it i i i spotted you and your
lovely wife right there on the field you
saw me and i came over and we
chit-chatted now the rest is history and
you're still happily married which is
great uh but i will be i will be on the
field on sunday night
the guys here don't even know it they
guys here don't even know it either here
in the studio i will be there i will i
can i cannot wait have you
have you not been in that stadium yet
right you haven't been in so far i
haven't it's a great opportunity to go
to one of the one of the pre-season
games but i i passed on it because i
just figured that
sunday night football was the perfect
introduction to the new stadium we go
with our friends george and alicia and
uh we we just wanted to all do it
together so i haven't inquired about
field passes or the field club which
immediately ironically is the only place
in the stadium that we don't have access
to with our tickets but uh
but i'm excited to see you
if i don't see you i'll tweet at you i
love it i will look forward to that uh
stephen amell uh one of the stars of
heels uh onstars here on the rich eisen
show um what do you think of stafford
joining the team and the rams
opportunity here peter king of uh of
football morning and football night in
america chose the rams to win super bowl
56 back-to-back years
of the home team
winning in their home stadium for the
super bowl what do you think about that
stephen amell i think i think that uh
there's a setting on the jet ski that i
have that's called speed mode now the
jet ski can go about 70 miles an hour
but you can set the speed boat for about
40 okay and then it won't go faster than
40 miles an hour and and with respect i
feel like that's been mcveigh with goth
for the past three years
and i think that stafford lets him go
70.
i'm fired up i think i mean i've watched
him since he was in georgia
um
you guys are studs i'm very excited i
have not heard coach quarterback
uh analogy
in relation to jet skis before stephen
that's a first for me but i think i i'm
picking up what you're putting down that
you think that you think that mcvea is
now going to be uh dangerously fast with
his mind and his offense
yeah well i was listening to bill
simmons talk about it too and there's
there's a lot of kyle shanahan hype and
there's a lot of this and there's a lot
of that i think that there's i think
that there's this moment right now where
mcveigh wants to remind everyone who the
young whiz kid is and i can say this
because i'm actually older than him
which which gives me pause
but i i just i i think that he's going
to unleash
the entire arsenal it was it was really
unfortunate that the cam akers went down
in the preseason because he started to
come on so much the end of last year and
was just so just such a monster in that
first playoff game against seattle but
um i don't know i i hopefully sony
michelle uh fills in that whole little
bit like cj anderson did in their super
bowl uh super bowl run year
but i i i'm excited i'm bullish although
all the people that are picking
them to go to and win the super bowl it
gives you pause for a second but
um look i'm going to have tickets if
they go
so let's hope let's hope here's hoping
and if not uh you could check out
stephen amell's uh i guess um
twitter page for the ability to
get his tickets i mean you're gonna put
your tickets up for sale otherwise or
not
it's working well i guess i guess it'll
i guess it'll kind of depend sorry my
wife's telling me that someone's sitting
beside you that i want to yell that i
want to yell his name who's this
tj hey tj how you doing
what up yo
man tell them i said hey okay now
this is amazing because tj knows
everybody tj
how do you know
steven's beloved oh man we've been
friends since she moved to l.a like i
don't know how many years ago cassandra
20 not even
15
she's my biggest fan believe it or not
okay look at that i had no idea tj knows
everybody
this is great
that's accurate that's an accurate
statement
i've got the whole
family i've got the whole amel family on
here tj it's amazing how many people
just shout you out i love it yeah i try
to be a good person rich
no idea
um well you asked you asked me if i was
gonna you asked me if i was gonna get
rid of my get rid of my tickets it's
really gonna be it's really gonna be a
game time decision i mean if the rams
aren't gonna be in there you really hope
that
you really hope that i can just peddle
those things like the cowboys or the
packers or the st a team that travels in
the fan base that spends money
um you know it'll it'll be difficult and
look one of the reasons i would sell it
is because i'm i'm fully prepared to
work as like a camera technician or
something for the nfl network
in the building
i will always help you we're moving into
new studios right next door uh tomorrow
as a matter of fact fun exciting i know
we are excited so let's talk about heels
here uh 9 p.m eastern on stars
um and a a neat story about a father who
bequeaths
a legacy to two kids and there's a
fight over it and i'll give you the
floor on what uh what you love about
this show
stephen wrestling i i grew up i i grew
up in my my passion before football or
baseball before the rams or the blue
jays or the raptors it was it was macho
man randy savage and curt henning and
hulk hogan and roddy piper
i grew up a huge wrestling fan pro
wrestling fan
and
you know there's the wwe and there's aew
but
uh what people don't see
uh you know if you're a baseball fan
like you know the the
buffalo bisons or the j's aaa team and
um you know there are triple a ranks for
pro wrestling like the duffy wrestling
league so we set this in guppy georgia
it's just about a small town league in a
small town community that doesn't have
so it's based in georgia and i have a
line where i say you know
we you know we don't have the bulldogs
we don't have the hawks we don't have
the braves
uh you know we don't have the falcons
what we got is adopted wrestling league
so everyone gets together every weekend
and they go out to the duffy dome and
it's a family drama that's set against
the backdrop of pro wrestling and um you
know and and if you need a if you need a
bigger hook uh we have quite possibly
one of the scariest defensive linemen in
nfl history james james harrison
just making a wonderful turn as a
character named apocalypse
aptly named on our show and uh
yeah that's it sunday night on stars
it's
a bunch of different ways to watch it
but um yeah
if you're interested
uh you can find it well of course it's
on stars and um
that was my next question is what's
harrison what's james harrison like on
the set
stephen you know what he threw i'll tell
you what we can make all the jokes about
you know
me being terrified of him because i am
for a good reason
uh but he couldn't be it couldn't be a
sweeter guy and he he threw himself into
he threw himself into acting uh and and
worked at it the way that i'm sure that
he had to work as as someone who wasn't
even drafted and spent you know five six
years toiling around nfl europe before
he finally got his chance with the
steelers he he he does a really good job
he plays a plays a character that um
is in recovery uh from alcoholism and
so he's got his funny moments and he's
got his he's got his his moments where
we use the physical gifts that
that james brings to the table but at
the same time it's in the quieter
moments like when he opens episode six
with uh with a speech leading an aaa
meeting and he just he knocks it out of
the park he he's really really really
talented well i mean
sorry go ahead no he must be really
talented stephen because the showrunner
of the program and the ep
is mike o'malley who could not be more
of a die-hard patriot fan and probably
despite harrison joining the team later
in his career couldn't have more
personal reasons for not wanting
harrison around
oh yeah you know so
there's a character there's a character
there's a character on the show uh that
uh played by trey tucker
uh who does it called bobby pin he does
who does a wonderful job but it was it
was real real close to being rob
gronkowski
so
is that right
yeah so yeah mike uh mike told us mike
told the story on the bill simmons
podcast where they went to his house he
read the parts he was ready and uh i
think at the time he actually made the
decision to go with the wwe
before
uh before uh before tommy called him up
and said it's time to
it's it's time to come back down and put
the helmet on gronk yeah i was about to
say just just trying to figure out when
you shot this and when when casting
would take place it would probably have
to be right around
gronk saying i'm going to come back and
play football which obviously has worked
out well
yeah originally uh so i was cast in
august of 2019 and then they started to
fill it out we were supposed to go to
camera in april of 2020
and then obviously that that got delayed
but that was that was right around the
time and then i think sort of was like
april may of 2020s during the during the
beginning months of the pandemic that
that grant decided to come back
well uh stephen congrats on the show
um i'll i'll look for it so far on
sunday night okay let's stay in touch
i'll see you i'll see you at the games
man i'll see you at the game hey rich i
really i really appreciate it thanks for
uh thanks for letting me uh come on and
promote the show of course anytime
stephen you know we we go way back and
glad to see that you and your wife are
still happily married despite despite me
being thrown into the mix uh on the
field at the super bowl a few years ago
stephen i'm glad okay well i'll see i'll
see you i'll see you on sunday yep i'm
looking decent these days so no i saw
that i still can't i still i still have
no the competition's over i mean it's
i'm getting i'm getting curb stomped on
that but it's okay i was just i'm just
gonna bring my own my own
um level of panache to the to the mix on
sunday night i'll be on the field you'll
see me i'll wave thank you take care
brother take care that's stephen amell
check out
him and the rest of the cast including
james harrison of heels
on show time on sundays at nine eastern
time
heels
tj knows everybody
right everybody knows tj that's the way
it goes it's his town
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here